una decisión que no fue fácil ni ética
ni moralmente de esta forma anunció el
presidente de israel reuvén rivlin el
encargo a benjamin netanyahu de la
formación de un nuevo gobierno no está
claro que netanyahu vaya a conseguir los
apoyos necesarios pero la alternativa
serían unas quintas elecciones en menos
de dos años
he tomado una decisión basada en el
número de recomendaciones que indican
que en miembro de la canna set benjamin
netanyahu tiene ligeramente más opciones
de formar gobierno por ello he decidido
confiar en la tarea de hacerlo
sola las elecciones del pasado 23 de
marzo dejaron un parlamento ampliamente
fragmentado que sin embargo se divide en
dos bloques principales a favor y en
contra de netanyahu
ninguno de los dos obtendría la mayoría
absoluta de 61 escaños para formar
gobierno y paradójicamente el partido
árabe islamista raam con cuatro escaños
podría tener la llave del futuro
político de israel
existe la posibilidad de que les veamos
formar parte de algún tipo de coalición
que netanyahu e intente formar también
existe la posibilidad que los apoyen
desde fuera del gobierno
en otras palabras será un gobierno en
minoría la posibilidad es real dada la
idiosincrasia de este partido expulsado
de la lista conjunta de partidos árabes
por su apertura a trabajar con netanyahu
para defender los intereses de la
minoría árabe pero los casos de
corrupción que persiguen al presidente
en funciones no harán fácil la tarea
este martes netanyahu se enfrenta
también a la segunda audiencia de la
fase probatoria del juicio que comenzó
ayer a ball motion also con lo que está
pasando es un esfuerzo para trampear la
democracia de los siglos boletus están
intentando anular los deseos del
electorado
un argumento que recuerda el del ex
presidente estadounidense donald trump
para no perder la presidencia los
próximos días decidirán si netanyahu
corre la misma suerte que su ex aliado
en la casa blanca